hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the fado early on in the discussion
remember the fado is
is about socrates very last days his
conversation with his friends
before he's uh going to be executed by
his own hand drinking poison
he tells his friends that a philosopher
is not going to be afraid of death or
see
death as a bad thing in part because
philosophy
is actually a preparation for death
the philosopher at one point he says
practices death gets ready for death
and they joke around a little bit
and and uh one of his interlocutors says
it's either sim yes or quebec says
well yeah you know the ordinary people
say you philosophers are half dead
anyway
you're insensible to the things that
everybody else cares about
you're not really like living people and
socrates will say they don't even know
how right they are
we are actually if we're doing
philosophy right
half dead now
what would that mean how does this make
sense
how can this actually be a good thing
isn't death a bad thing
so socrates starts out by saying okay
what is death it's really a liberation
of the soul
from the body and you notice they have
here in parentheses
that the soul is still living the soul
is actually in the fado
and for socrates the principle of life
in a in some ways the soul is more alive
than the body is
and if you take the soul away from the
body the body falls apart and decomposes
the soul
goes on so death doesn't mean
the total cessation of everything unless
there is no soul and it's just a body
and he's going to consider that in other
arguments
but for socrates what we really are
is the soul the body is just a shell
that we are stuck with and which makes
all sorts of demands upon us
and which we are deceived into thinking
is
us so for example i think that i'm six
foot three
that i have long hair tied into a
ponytail that i'm you know i've got a
body that's 44 years old
um hands that are pale
you know fingers that are long um
i have a certain build all these sorts
of things
i associate with myself and i think of
that as me
strictly speaking you know if you adopt
the perspective that plato has
our souls aren't even really
gendered they don't have an age i
suppose not in the sense that you know i
can say that i'm middle aged or anything
like that
if anything they're very very old and
we're trying to liberate that
that that thing that's really us from
this this shell
that it occupies in this lifetime
so if that's really the case
i've got a little misspelling here
notice
if that's really the case then the
philosopher
is actually looking forward as he says
to death
but what does it mean to look forward to
death it doesn't mean a sort of morbid
uh boy i can't wait until i die because
it's going to be so cool when there's
nobody here
you know this is a little bit off topic
but it's it's a good
classical reference there's this
scene in tom sawyer and many of us have
read tom sawyer
and sort of required reading in middle
school or high school
there's this scene where tom sawyer
shows up in the town for his own funeral
because they don't know that he's not
dead and he gets to hear everybody you
know lamenting over him and this is
actually a fantasy that a lot of people
have you know what's it going to be like
when i'm when i'm dead and gone
plato's not talking about that at all
that would still be a this worldly kind
of thing
instead he's talking about the
philosopher looking forward
to this liberation which is preparing
them
to launch into eternity to be with the
things
that are actually the most real to not
be bothered
with the things that are actually false
changing deceiving mutable
many unreliable
the things that are of this material
world including our own bodies
so the philosopher is going through the
work
of trying to prepare for this
and how how do you do this well
um they're not on the one hand going to
concern themselves once again
misspelling they're not going to concern
themselves
with bodily desires and pleasures as a
matter of fact socrates is this great
you know set of questions during his
typical socratic method
and he says um
the uh the people who are are you know
concerned with this sort of thing
um what are they going to be doing are
they going to be concerning themselves
with the pleasures of the body
here we go um
are they going to concern themselves
with you know food and drink
and thirst and hunger are they going to
concern themselves with the
pleasures or the desires of the sexual
appetite
the aphrodisiac in greek named after
aphrodite
so you know they say no the philosopher
is not going to be concerned with
things of the body and in our own time
we might say
you know if we want to be very specific
about this sort of thing is the
philosopher going to be somebody who
cares about how many friends they have
on facebook
or how many twitter followers they have
or what the comments
from the many are on the videos that
they upload
are they going to care about whether
their clothes are
current in fashion or um
out of fashion are they going to care
very much about
the kind of food that they're putting on
the table or not are they going to be
content with ordinary fare
are they going to are they going to be
particularly concerned if they are
having sexual relations with the person
and how they look or you know whether
they're
in great shape have a wonderful body or
are they going to be more concerned
about the connection of minds that's
taking place the connection of
of souls this is not something that he's
talking about here
that's in the symposium or the phaedras
or other
uh dialogues but it we could extrapolate
from this the philosopher is going to
abstract from the things of the body
the desires the pleasures that are
solely bodily that are only concerned
with things that you can locate in space
and time
instead what are they going to do
they're going to focus
on attaining knowledge
now here's where we need to say
something
about the platonic conception of
knowledge
you might say well the soul is going to
carry around this knowledge you know
we've got this in
this sort of imagination of i've got a
head and it's you know full of knowledge
and we we met we we create metaphors
visual metaphors with this sort of thing
but really knowledge for plato is not
something
that's within the soul and which the
soul carries around with it it's more a
relation
of the soul to what is what is
ultimately known
the forms the unchanging
eternal immutable entities that
are what it is that the things that we
know participate in
and that's not going to be gained by
just going off to school and reading
books or something like that
it involves a process of contemplation i
should also say here
dialectic because that's the other
tool that socrates talks about over and
over again
and that plato saw is as essential it's
really poorly written there but you can
read it anyway
so the philosopher is going to
concentrate
not on spending their time pursuing the
things of the body
but rather on pursuing knowledge
contemplation
and they're also going to have to
practice the virtues
and he talks about four virtues in this
the cardinal virtues of
justice he doesn't talk that much about
justice but he does talk about
courage and temperance and then he talks
about wisdom
phronesis in other dialogues sophia
in greek and wisdom
is the currency that all these other
virtues can be measured by
and he says that and i've got a whole
video specifically about philosophical
temperance and courage which you can
take a look at
he says that wisdom is a kind of
purification and these virtues are also
types of purification
and wisdom is what governs them so to
having temperance means having a certain
kind of freedom
from being driven by your appetites your
appetites for food your appetite for sex
your appetite for
laying around your appetite for having
you know comfortable clothes or things
like that
you you stop paying attention to those
sorts of things
because those just tie you to the body
those just tie you to this this world
that we're currently in
instead you prepare for your liberation
of the soul from the body by trying in
this
life to be as unconcerned with things of
the body as possible
and instead use the time that you have
to
focus on contemplation to focus on
developing the virtues the virtues by
the way
are some of the things that we
contemplate the forms there is a form of
justice
out there that plato thinks that if
we're really
doing philosophy we connect ourselves up
with that we get to see
these these forms so if you have this
sort of point of view
philosophy then becomes
a preparation for dying not a
preparation for dying as in you know
like writing your will
and saying my books are going to go to
so and so and i need to leave enough
money behind for my wife and kids
or what's going to happen with my dogs
it's not that sort of thing that would
be this worldly
instead it's a concern with what is most
us
according to plato are our immortal
souls
and what's going to happen to them plato
also thinks that
if you do this if you carry out this
process of
esthesis or disciplining
you will free yourself from the fate
of most of the other souls which is to
be trapped in this material world